[Musique]
je m'appelle peter parker la suite je
suis sûr que vous la connaissez j'ai
sauvé la ville je suis tombé amoureux et
après j'ai sauvé la ville encore une
fois et encore une fois et encore une
fois je suis partout dans les comics sur
les paquets de céréales je me fais un
album de chants de noël et je suis une
glace assez bof mais il s'agit pas de
moi enfin plus maintenant
spider man il déboule au bout de son
fils une fois par jour bim bam boum
derrière son masque qui rendent compte à
personne je t'aime maïs ouais je sais
papa c'est là que tu réponds je t'aime
non mais t'es sérieux
vas-y je t'écoute à vue on est papa je
t'aime papa je t'aime reçu cinq sur cinq
je m'appelle miles morales je suis le
seul et unique spider man
du moins c'est ce que je croyais
l'accélérateur de particules déconner tu
vas adorer 10 ou encore de vertueux tu
es comme moi comment c'est possible
ok tiga écoute bien cette fritz et ton
univers toute molle tordu et des lieux
et s'effritent croquante et délicieuse
c'est mon univers
alors tu veux devenir spiderman ou
pouvait m'apprendre je peux faire sa
place à la voltige ou bien tu te
débrouilles double clic pour libérer et
pictural en dames à valence et je l'y
verra donc
salut les gars on se tutoie moi c'est
gwen stacy
j'ai besoin d'une autre autre dimension
mais il y en a combien et spider héros
salut les amis je crois que là on peut
pas faire plus bizarres ok si on peut
faire plus bizarres et ben ça promet on
doit retourner dans mon univers est vite
revenu s'effondrer
ma famille vit la moquerie au miles
qu'est ce qui se passe ça n'a jamais été
ma ville c'est la mienne
je décris pas l'accélérateur de
particules on pourra pas empêcher nous
on aura fait chez nous
plus jamais c'est grâce à ta différence
ses papiers que tuer spider man
monsieur l'agent je t'aime un quoi
[Musique]
du côté de ce côté que le protelos côté
le protège les animaux parlent dans
cette dimension je voudrais pas qu'il ai
la trouille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]